So I will be talking about teens today.
Um,
thanks for coming.
Over the last month we've watched hundreds of thousands of teenagers organize
and participate in massive rallies across the country.
They've done this in the face of both pain and serious frustration that adults
have utterly failed them on something very,
very basic that's keeping schools safe.
Adults who have been unable to achieve common sense gun control following mass
shooting after mass shooting are now placing their hands and this younger
generation.
But isn't this like the same generation that made tide pods eating tide pods of
viral sensation and recent weeks?
Like how much do you really understand today's young people and how much do you
even care?
For most old people,
the answer is very little.
They don't care,
but you should care like the,
this is the generation that will create massive change in the world over the
next 50 years.
And for us to be able to like teach and influence them as they begin to make
those changes,
it's super important that we understand them.
So if you allow,
allow me to be your guide,
I'd like to tell you a little bit about today's teenager.
But first a little bit about me.
My name is Cory Levy.
I'm in my mid twenties,
and although I'll be using the word we,
while I present this information,
teens consider me a little old.
Um,
so I've worked like years to stay on top of this generation.
Has Jesse mentioned,
um,
I started a company called after school while I was a teenager,
while I was 19.
Um,
uh,
afterschool is one of the largest teenage social networks in the,
in the u s millions of users who are currently in high school.
I'm also on the board of do something.org,
which is a nonprofit,
a digital platform powering social change for nearly 6 million young people.
Um,
and today I'm going to help you understand this generation a bit better.
So,
um,
uh,
over the last few weeks I've been interviewing teenagers and with the help from
teams across the country,
I've made a list of 10 things that you,
you probably don't understand,
um,
uh,
today about,
about teenagers.
Um,
so we'll get started.
The first point is we're heavily addicted to our phones,
but we don't know our phone numbers,
which,
you know,
the first part,
you probably already know.
The second part was what's a little surprising to me and how is this possible?
I've obviously,
you know,
like teams grew up,
um,
uh,
with,
with iPhones and Androids,
with smartphones,
they're,
they're more reliant on them than,
than,
than ever before.
Um,
but teenagers,
they care more about like usernames.
Um,
what's their snapchat name?
What's their Instagram handle?
Um,
they don't really care about phone numbers when they meet new people for the
first time.
They're exchanging these handles,
not like,
Hey,
what's your number?
It's like,
Hey,
um,
you know,
add me on snapchat or,
or,
or follow me on Instagram.
They don't use iMessage or SMS because mom and dad can,
can,
can have access to that.
They're,
they're texting on snapchat and,
and,
and an Instagram DM.
And they've probably never,
never,
never used this thing the way it was invented.
Um,
which is probably never,
never,
uh,
use,
use the actual phone.
They've never used an alarm clock.
Um,
they just use,
you use their phone for that and doorbells.
They're like,
what's that?
And that totally unnecessary.
Um,
uh,
and peers,
how,
like two teenagers that,
that I interviewed,
um,
kind of described their connections to their phone.
Teenagers are digital natives.
They don't live in a mobile friendly world.
There are more mobile only generation.
Um,
another person who's a senior in high school said,
parents just don't understand why we move from thing to thing so quickly.
It's not that we have a short attention span is our generation's ability to
filter through information more quickly because we just get bombarded with it so
much.
Um,
this is point number two.
Facebook is lame.
Um,
we love streaks.
Uh,
teams think Facebook is,
is for their grandparents.
It's old,
clunky and invasive.
And in fact,
it's one of the reasons that,
that we,
um,
that we developed our APP after school,
which helps teens connect and share with other students at their high school.
Um,
millions of users.
We have like a matching feature that's connected over a,
that's been used over a billion times with a B.
Um,
uh,
we just released a compliment feature and in the last 24 hours,
like hundreds of thousands of teenagers have,
have like complemented each other with that.
And,
um,
what we've seen with,
with afterschool is that teens use us because we're like a teen only social
network to um,
you know,
come,
come to use the product to,
to uh,
to post things that like they wouldn't post on Facebook or Twitter or Instagram
because there is an anonymous feature to it.
Um,
we also connect teenagers with crisis text line when they are in need,
need of help.
Crisis textline is a teen hotline that you can text seven,
four one seven,
four one.
And uh,
instead of like calling a hotline,
you can text with a trained crisis counselor.
We've connected over 100,000 teenagers to crisis textline via,
um,
via our APP.
Um,
but,
but probably one of the most popular ways that,
that,
that teams communicate is snaps.
Raise your hand if you know what a streak is
about half the audience.
Um,
uh,
teens are like obsessed with snap streaks and a little bit of what a snap streak
is when you send direct snaps back and forth,
four consecutive days.
So if me and you snapped each other today,
tomorrow,
and the next day we would have had a a three day snap streak and the longer you
go without breaking the chain,
the longer your,
your community,
the longer your streak is.
And teenagers that I have,
like streaks that have lasted not just weeks or months,
but years,
um,
uh,
snap rewards these longer streets like special emojis.
So you get a hundred street,
you get like the little hundred Emoji or like a mountain Emoji for like an
extremely,
uh,
long streak.
There's,
there's nothing more devastating to a teenager then like losing that streak when
they go off to camp for like a week or a month,
they'll give their snap password to a friend.
Um,
just so they can,
they can keep their,
their streaks going.
Um,
uh,
here's how a 16 year old from Brooklyn,
um,
put it streaks are a big part of social acceptance.
Having more streaks makes you feel way more popular.
But he added,
I think,
streaks are a way of showing how many people you talk to.
It's like a score.
If you see your friends have a lot of streaks,
you're like,
Whoa,
that guy or girl knows a lot of people.
It shows her social status to see how many streaks they have.
Um,
so snap streaks is something that is incredibly popular amongst teenagers and
teens also.
Um,
also love,
love,
love Instagram.
Instagram,
Instagram live is particularly popular.
Um,
this allows them to connect with their,
with their followers like an in and their audience in real time.
And another,
like a,
an important trend that's popped up is something called a Finsta.
Raise your hand if you've heard of a Finsta one per two people in the audience.
Um,
offense.
Finsta stands for a fake Instagram.
So teenagers will have,
um,
uh,
two Instagrams set up.
One is their main Instagram,
and that's where their parents,
their siblings,
their cousins,
their friends will follow them.
And then they had a second Instagram called a Finsta,
which stands for fake Instagram.
And that's where they um,
uh,
just have their like top,
you know,
friends,
no parents,
no teachers,
no cousins,
um,
that,
that follow them.
And uh,
yeah,
17 year old student I talked you described for the fence.
So she goes on my fence.
That's the good,
the bad and the ugly.
It's the more multifaceted version of me.
Um,
and you know,
many teams are aware that like potential employers and colleges will,
will have access to their,
their maintenance scratch or they create a create the second Instagram called
offense stuff to keep,
you know,
some of the information private.
Um,
uh,
a 16 year old I interviewed said,
people in my ige or always doing Instagram lives usually for attention.
Something I do unconsciously is pull out snapchat anytime anything interesting
is happening,
especially around New York City.
A majority of my videos on my phone are in stat memories.
Anytime I take a video it's for snap for sure.
Just because it's easy to share.
So teens today aren't using like the default camera on their phones.
They aren't using the default apple or Google camera when they want to.
Take a photo,
they're going to snapchat,
taking a photo and then saving it and then debating whether or not to send it
out.
Um,
which was,
which was surprising to me.
Point number three,
we're modern day Shakespeare's.
So teenagers are creating like,
you know,
new language every single day.
Um,
and you know,
we,
we usually start copying them,
uh,
w eventually.
So I want to share like some examples of what teams are saying today.
A M o s c as an acronym it kids are using to,
uh,
basically just means add me on snapchat.
Bad means good.
Surprising prog means,
Bro.
Cringe is when something is like gross or awkward or uncomfortable,
um,
curve or swerve some times is,
is,
is to reject someone.
Don't add me.
And he's like,
don't call me out or don't disagree with me.
I'm Finna,
it's like I'm fixing to or are Gunna then,
so,
which I just described as the fake Instagram,
um,
goat acronym that stands for greatest of all time.
Gucci,
not the brand,
it means good.
Um,
I'm weak or dead is like,
that's so funny.
That's hilarious.
Kms is like the new FML.
Um,
savage is,
is,
you know,
bold or strong,
um,
low key.
Do you want to say something?
Low Key.
It's like secretive and hierarchy.
That means it's not secretive and it's something that everyone should know.
Plug someone that can provide them with something shipped.
It's not like shipping a product,
but more like a relationship like Alex and Sarah should be shipped off together
means they should be in a relationship.
Um,
straight fire is like good or trendy.
to describe your friend group.
They're using both squad and fam.
Um,
and uh,
to be bitter is salty.
Um,
straight fires like that.
That's also another,
another term they use for good or trendy.
And then Tsas,
um,
is a term that we're using for something that's like suspicious.
So,
um,
uh,
you know,
you might hear a news reporter and a few months saying like what Facebook did
was,
so sauce,
it's little,
little example.
Um,
so this won't be on the midterm,
but she should,
uh,
definitely know what teams are the words that they're saying,
but,
but you know,
like team teams are,
are,
are moving beyond words.
Um,
they,
they've made popular in a ray of like new communication techniques.
Um,
uh,
emojis means gifts to express their emotions quickly.
Um,
if you look at any teens tax conversation,
you'll immediately notice the difference with adult tax teams.
Use like tons of Emojis,
gifs,
memes and um,
uh,
this,
this makes complete sense there.
They're used to like a flood of information I've been to have had become like
really,
really good at processing quickly and conveying ideas quickly and it's much more
efficient for them to use like an Emoji or a gift and like four,
10 words to describe what they,
what they want to community,
what they want to communicate.
Um,
teens,
they don't get why,
um,
why you are so close.
Closed minded teams think that adults are close minded when it comes to things
like same sex marriage,
different sexual orientation,
mixed race dating.
Um,
and this makes sense when you consider their part of the,
like the most racially diverse generation in America,
48% of them are non white.
81% of them have different,
uh,
have friends that are,
that are,
that are different race.
And 35% of them have dated,
um,
a different race as well.
One,
one team put it,
most kids like myself and especially ones in urban environments care about the
rights of themselves,
but also people that don't look like them or share similar attributes.
And that's the reason why we,
we actually go out and protest at City Hall.
He,
it's hard for adults who are stuck in their ways to see when change is
necessary.
This one,
uh,
may or may not be surprising to you,
but gamers are heroes,
not geeks.
Teens still love like they're movie stars,
musicians,
athletes,
et cetera.
But,
but who can be a celebrity has changed quite some time.
Um,
they idolize vloggers like Jake Paul who has nearly 15 million youtube
subscribers and videos are being viewed billions of times a month.
Um,
I was lucky enough to be one of his first investors in his management company
when he was 17 years old.
Um,
a fellow entrepreneurs like Elon Musk and Gary Vaynerchuk and Peter Teal and,
and,
and Mark Cuban and Tim Cook and perhaps like the most interesting thing.
Um,
uh,
they've made east sports figures.
They're heroes.
Um,
east sports stadiums are being built across the country and Vegas and Houston
and Dallas.
Um,
uh,
and you know,
pro video game players have these massive followings like major corporate
sponsorships and they compete in these huge arenas and make way more money than
like regular regular athletes.
There's a 26 year old named Ninja.
I'm raise your hand if you've heard of Ninja two people.
Um,
as sort of Ninja,
he's,
he's the most popular Gamer on twitch.
Um,
uh,
earns more than half a million dollars a month,
just by playing video games.
Um,
fortnight is a massive game that's super popular amongst teenagers.
A Ninja just played fortnight in front of 600,000 people viewing it at the same
time.
Drake,
the rapper came on and played with him.
Um,
uh,
Juju,
Smith,
Schuster,
Steelers foot,
a wide receiver came on and played with him.
Um,
this is something that is,
that is,
that is just the very,
very beginning and continuing to,
to,
to blow up one team.
Put it while athletes and movie stars are still famous,
the idolization of entrepreneurs like Gary,
um,
and youtube bloggers and influencers has completely changed the perception.
The fact that an entrepreneur came out with a,
with a shoe and sold it out to kids and,
and seconds is unreal.
Highschoolers are paying more and more attention to east sports.
And so as the world,
for example,
fortnight or Ninja,
the best player in the world played with Drake Juju,
Smith's Schuster and then a rapper Travis Scott as I mentioned earlier,
had over 600,000 people viewing it,
um,
uh,
at at the same time.
Um,
fashion is still really big amongst today's young people.
Streetwear,
um,
a reign supreme team today differentiate themselves in many ways.
And when it,
when it comes to fashion,
teens increasingly choose like streetwear brands like supreme and van's over
mainstream.
Brands like Nike,
um,
supreme has this like particular kind of outsider appeal for teenagers.
Even though,
you know,
the brand launched in 1994 in New York City as a,
as a skateboarding and clothing company,
um,
it caters to the skate and hip hop cultures,
but,
and to just youth cultures and in,
in general.
And it's become an absolute obsession for,
for,
for teenagers when teens here about kind of a new shoe or product launch on
Reddit or other social media,
hundreds of teams will line up in New York,
um,
to get their hands on the product before it sells out.
And a lot of teams are entrepreneurs.
They'll buy it and then immediately flip it for,
um,
uh,
extreme markups and,
and big finance is starting to pay attention to this.
The car out group invested in supereme and valued the company at over over a
billion dollars.
We have no interest in working at big companies,
so most teams have,
have very little working,
uh,
very little interest in working for major corporations.
Even,
you know,
tech ones like,
like Amazon and Facebook,
they,
they've seen their parents and older siblings kind of struggle in the workforce
and become unhappy to spite these high paying jobs.
Uh,
teams today are more entrepreneurial than,
than older generations and have like less patients for bureaucratic work
environments and crave more independence.
72% of them said they wanted to start a business one day,
uh,
which is,
which is pretty,
pretty fascinating.
Number nine,
you've left us with a big mess to clean up.
Teams have grown up watching no reports of of a broken political system,
devastating climate change,
you know,
mass shootings at schools,
homegrown terrorism and ongoing war.
It's no surprise that like 68% of the,
of this generation feel the u s has headed in the wrong direction and 44% are
worried about the way that things are going.
This was more than any other generation,
um,
uh,
interviewed and,
and um,
you know,
lastly,
teens think that that will have a bigger impact than,
than you think.
Um,
it's easy for adults to think that teens today are pretty reckless.
A much of what we read or hear in the media focuses on the,
on the negatives.
I'm like teams trying to pull off crazy stunts on youtube,
which I'm sure you have seen,
or teens infatuation with the jewel.
Raise your hand if you've heard of the jewel one person.
Again,
I'm the jewel is a sleek e-cigarette that can be like used indoors without
attracting attention.
Um,
and don't get me wrong,
like the massive popularity of this jewel of e-cigarettes and something that,
that,
that we should be concerned about.
Um,
but,
uh,
the jewel is something that is a massively popular amongst,
amongst teenagers.
Um,
but,
but these types of behaviors are really not much different than the kind of what
we were like in prior generations.
And one team described it as just like the generations before them.
Teams will always want to rebel against the norm.
We're,
we're not worse.
It's just that you see it more because everything is being recorded.
So focusing on these,
these,
these negatives makes us lose sight of the bigger picture with thousands of
hours of kind of observing teams has shown me what many studies show is that
today's teams,
um,
they have a strong worth ethic and balance forward thinking with kind of old
school,
traditional values.
Um,
so when,
when adults think about this new generation,
we should be open minded,
teams are,
are,
are multifaceted.
Um,
and,
uh,
you know,
it's gonna,
it's gonna gonna take some time for us to like stick with a name for this next
generation.
But when I asked teenagers,
like,
tell me if you can name your generation,
what would you name it?
Here's some of the responses that I got.
You know,
the viral generation,
the founders I generation,
um,
uh,
digital natives,
gen mobile generation,
next,
the connected generation,
um,
et cetera.
So these were some of the names.
These are some of the names that I got when I,
when I asked a bunch of teenagers,
you know,
how would you,
if you can name it,
name your generation,
what would it be?
But regardless of of what they're called.
Um,
I think one thing is really clear and that is that we shouldn't underestimate
today's teenagers.
Like,
yes,
you know,
they,
they use phones in different ways that,
that,
that we probably would have never imagined the idolize these e sports stars that
we've never heard of.
And they can be pretty quirky,
but,
but they're already showing us that they're going to step up and tackle like
major challenges in ways that other generations haven't.
Last weekend's like march for our lives was,
was one example that was organized by teenagers.
It brought over 800,000 people,
um,
uh,
to Washington,
DC and countless more,
uh,
to hundreds of sister marches across the country.
This is more than the inaugural women's March.
The,
the,
um,
the million man march and,
and,
you know,
didn't,
uh,
what else?
The march on Washington for jobs and freedom,
um,
800,000 was the biggest march ever.
And you know,
today's teams,
they've,
they have energy,
that passion and they have a no nonsense attitude about fixing the problems
that,
that they've,
that they've inherited.
And if what they've accomplished in the last month is,
is any kind of indication we old people are in pretty good hands.
Um,
so thank you for listening to these,
these 10 points.
Hopefully you,
you learned a little something today and,
and the 20 or 30 minutes at a time that I had.
Um,
and I'm happy to,
to answer any questions that you have on today's generation of teenagers.
Okay.
So I know that online bullying is a,
is a kind of uniquely bad problem for this generation and I was kind of curious
what your social network is doing to mitigate that problem.
Yeah.
So online bullying is,
is a,
a VR very,
very serious problem for pretty much any big social network.
Um,
one of the things that we do is proactive moderation.
So most social networks do reactive moderation when they,
uh,
when someone posts a message to Twitter or to Facebook,
it gets seen by everyone.
If it is a,
a negative message,
it may get taken down after the fact.
Um,
with afterschool we do proactive moderation.
So someone writes a message,
it has to get seen by moderation in order for it to get seen by others.
Um,
so that's,
that's,
you know,
one of the steps that we take,
um,
uh,
and after school and we hope that other social networks will follow,
which is increased moderation.
Um,
and um,
yeah,
uh,
what's up in the back,
right.
So streaks definitely seems like a pretty ingenious gamification to encourage
more usage and so forth.
Uh,
any other examples of those sorts of gamification elements,
whether a in your social network or others that you've seen and,
and other social networks?
You know,
obviously likes is
something that,
that,
that teens care a lot about.
One of the things that I've noticed is that when a teenager posts up on
Instagram,
they will wait for like five or 10 minutes,
and if it doesn't get some threshold number of likes,
they'll delete the post.
Um,
so,
so likes is something that,
um,
is,
is incredibly important to them.
Um,
uh,
and you know,
snap streaks is probably the best example of gamification that I've seen over
the last,
you know,
several years of following this generation.
Um,
if snap didn't have snap streaks,
I mean I think teams would,
would uh,
use it way,
way,
way less and best friends,
they have another thing called best friends.
I don't know if y'all don't know what snap best friends are,
but um,
uh,
if you just snap someone a bunch,
they'll have a little emoji next to next to that person's name.
And each Emoji may mean that you all are each best friends with each other or
one of you is best if it's a wink,
it's one of you is best friends with the other person,
the other person is not best friends with you.
I'm just snap is probably done the best job of,
of gameification.
And those are,
those are two examples of that.
Thanks.
You mentioned that 70% of teens wanted their own business.
If I remember going.
Yeah.
I wonder if this is the related,
uh,
what do they think of colleges,
college debt and nontraditional mutation things?
Do they also think differently than if we were in the past?
I'm sorry,
could you speak so that I had you,
there's so many people have college debt that is basically there's a prognosis
that of people who are freshmen this year,
but the person who would default on student loans are virtually.
So I wonder if students also have some very interesting ideas of like how to
not,
and I've been in data,
maybe do something different for a college education.
Uh,
um,
most teens are still following that traditional path of going to high school,
graduating,
going to college.
And Corinne is that,
um,
uh,
and then quickly realizing when they graduate that they weren't trained
properly,
gender,
you know,
uh,
the workforce.
So I don't think we're there yet.
Um,
uh,
I hope one day that we do get there were teams realize that,
you know,
paying $200,000 over the course of four years for,
random x degree may not mean that they're going to get a high paying job to pay
that off.
Um,
so I think,
uh,
your teams are so,
they care so much about themselves and their friends that they don't really know
much about.
Um,
uh,
you know,
what that means.
Um,
what college means to and what going in debt means.
So,
yeah.
Not yet.
Well,
cause you do things a bit difference between a high schoolers and middle
schoolers are they,
they use social media in a similar way today.
So high scores middle schooler is completely different.
Um,
uh,
you know,
some parents don't let their middle schoolers,
get,
get Instagram or snap chat until they reach a certain age.
Um,
some of the,
the,
the middle schoolers like they're using musically,
um,
they're starting their own slime businesses on Instagram or they make slime and
sell it.
Um,
uh,
middle schoolers are,
I've seen like a bunch of entrepreneurial characteristics.
Um,
but,
but don't,
don't,
don't know them super well,
but,
uh,
but yeah,
I do see pretty big differences from middle school,
high school and college.
In terms of,
of,
of network use.
I have heard about the detachment from TAC overall is the new trend.
What do you say that it's not a trend for teenagers,
but for all generations?
W what was the trend?
A detachment from technology?
Oh,
did
attachment from technology.
So,
um,
I think teens are there are very self aware that they're addicted to their
phones.
Um,
they,
you know,
if you go go to a high school and watch people during lunch,
like everyone will be like this.
Um,
uh,
yesterday I was with a group of,
of 80 teenagers and we were looking at their snap scores.
Snap score means,
you know,
when I send one stat message,
I get a point when I receive snap message,
I get to point,
uh,
you know,
an additional 0.1 teenager and this was like kind of like the average had over
600,000 points,
which means that the average was like,
you know,
she had a snapchat for a year or two or three or whatever it was.
She was sending 14 snaps an hour,
24 hours a day.
Um,
so I think teens are very self aware of that,
that,
uh,
you know,
that they're addicted to their phones,
but they don't really care like there,
I think when you,
when you go to college,
um,
that's maybe when you start to figure out,
you know,
how do I manage my time differently and how can I be more,
um,
uh,
productive.
But today's teenagers are,
uh,
pretty much like this all of the time.
What do you think teenagers perception of Vr is today?
Like teenagers,
perception of Vr?
I think some of the like,
uh,
you know,
the longer tail of,
of,
of teenagers are,
are super interested in it.
Um,
uh,
and I think there'll be like the early adopters to,
to the technology,
but you know,
the devices are expensive,
so,
um,
it's kind of tough for them to get their hands on it.
Um,
but,
uh,
but yeah,
I think younger generation generally set those trends and I think,
um,
uh,
VR will,
will be really big,
uh,
amongst soon.
I think there's like a question to the right of you.
Um,
I wanted to know a bit more about the after school app and how you think you
want over their trust to post things like you showed us and also like how you
convince them that it's worth their time to spend on the APP.
Yeah.
So the first question,
yeah.
How we kind of a win win over their trust.
I think,
uh,
we built a product for teenagers.
Um,
most people don't do that.
Most people just build a product for everyone.
Um,
uh,
and so our product was built just for them.
Um,
so,
so they know when they like download the APP that there's a verification
process.
I need to get past this,
a few number of things to kind of prove that they're,
they're a teenager and that they attend that high school.
So there's a level of,
of,
of safety that they feel like when I'm joining this network,
I had to jump through all these hoops to like prove I was a student.
Um,
uh,
and just so I think they liked that.
You know,
one high schooler was telling me that they posted some photo on Facebook and it
was like to impress a girl and the grandmother commented like,
Oh my God,
you're so cute.
And I was like,
the last time you used Facebook.
Um,
uh,
so I think people,
teenagers are attracted to after school because it's just for them and there no
grandparents or no,
you know,
teachers on the platform.
Um,
and it's a place where they can just,
you know,
feel comfortable.
Um,
yeah.
Yeah.
The other question is like,
how did you convince them it's worth their time?
Like they have a bunch of other stuff going on in high school.
Yeah.
Um,
that's a great question.
How do we convince them that it's worth their time?
I don't have like,
uh,
a perfect answer to that question.
Like our,
our apps grown kind of 100% through,
through word of mouth.
I think there's,
there's probably like a really big demand needed for teenagers to be in this
place,
which just them and their friends,
we all had that.
Or at least I had that one when I was growing up.
I had Facebook to go to and,
um,
when I was in high school and there were no,
there were no teachers or parents on Facebook.
It was just me and Mike,
my high school buddies.
Um,
so I think there was,
there was a big demand to create a space where it's just them and their friends.
Um,
uh,
and you know,
snapchat kind of helps a little bit with that,
although parents are,
are joining snap a lot right now.
But,
um,
but yeah,
so I think just creating that space just for them.
Yeah.
I just had another question.
Did they say anything about when they think like snapchat's going to die out or
Instagram is going to,
yeah,
so I think,
I think there's,
uh,
you know,
this is kind of the circle that we see where,
Facebook,
they started with the college audience,
their audience kind of grew up,
uh,
and then they started to build for like a wider audience and then they neglected
their original audience and collected,
you know,
young people,
um,
as they wanted to.
Just gain more users and bigger numbers for,
for you know,
investors and,
and their business.
Um,
so I think we're starting to see a little bit of that right now with Instagram
and snapchat are their parents and their grandparents are starting to join those
platforms that will drive the teams out to something different.
Um,
uh,
team's response to Instagram was,
well,
great,
if my grandparents and parents are on this,
I'm just going to create this second Instagram that they're not going to know
about.
Um,
uh,
with snapchat a little bit harder to do.
Um,
uh,
but with snap new update,
if y'all are familiar with that,
that's like lower the engagement I imagined massively amongst teenagers and the
ones that I talked to her like,
yeah,
with the new update,
like I don't use the scupper anymore.
I don't,
you know,
they're on it less so I'm not sure that was the,
uh,
the best update for snapchat with respect to teenagers.
So how do you prevent the parents or grandparents to come to after school?
It has,
so how do we prevent the old people from,
from infiltrating our network?
Uh,
basically it's a verification process.
So when you log into the APP,
you show us your like school id or verify in a,
in a,
in a certain way.
And a that's similar to how,
you know,
Facebook,
when they started,
you got to verify with your.edu address,
um,
uh,
to prove that you're a college student.
We do,
we do things similar,
so.
Okay.
So,
um,
so compared with this,
I feel that Google is so old.
Do any of your,
uh,
how,
how many,
you know,
usage of your audience actually use Google?
How many,
uh,
actually you just Google it.
Well,
yeah,
they,
they love Google because it helps them with their homework.
Um,
uh,
but,
but yeah,
I'm not,
uh,
you know,
it's the default web browser,
um,
for them.
So I think they're using it from,
you know,
just probably how,
or at least how I used it in high school.
It's just like,
I want to know anything.
It's okay to go to Google.
It helps me with my homework.
Okay.
Um,
and that's probably,
I would imagine what they did tribute Google to most.
It's like the thing that helps me with my homework.
Okay.
What's the one thing that you believe about teens and nobody else believes?
Nobody else believes?
Well,
I think teenagers,
um,
uh,
I think adults think teens are rebels.
And I think that,
that they're,
uh,
you know,
too addicted to their phones,
they're going to mess up the whole,
you know,
they're going to mess up the whole next generation.
And I disagree with that.
I think that that,
um,
you know,
today's teenagers are more capable than ever to like make change.
And we're seeing examples of that with this,
you know,
March for our lives,
um,
uh,
demonstration.
Um,
just to say that like a few teenagers plan this massive rally,
um,
you would've never thought that was possible five years ago or 10 years ago.
But with social media,
um,
with Twitter,
with Facebook,
with Instagram,
et Cetera,
we're able to,
to,
uh,
you know,
one kid in a school is able to make this,
this,
this massive change.
So I think this is like the first really big example of this,
but we're going to see so much more of this,
um,
and the days,
weeks and years to come.
So,
uh,
and I imagine if you interviewed a bunch of old people,
they'd be like,
no,
they're definitely not.
But that's one thing I disagree with.
I was wondering if you could speak more to like,
um,
the method of collecting this information and if you have any tips of like that
you've learned from,
uh,
methods that worked well versus others that might have been misleading,
if you can,
to collect this information about teenagers.
Yes.
Yeah,
so,
so that's,
that's a great question.
Um,
uh,
you know,
teenagers have different personas.
It's,
they're around their friends.
It's one,
one way they act when they're around adults.
They actually incredibly different.
Um,
so it's really challenging to kind of get,
um,
uh,
real truth,
a true,
true information about teenagers.
So a couple of ways we do it as one,
and we luckily had this,
this app that,
that millions of teenagers are communicating on.
Two we're able to like,
you know,
pick up trends in language that they're using just from,
the posts at the,
that they,
that they write.
Additionally,
we have like a bunch of ambassadors across America and,
uh,
we,
we kind of asked them to help us,
you know,
hey,
Texas to your friend texts,
these questions to your friends.
Um,
you know,
take a screenshot of,
uh,
the,
the people you follow,
the people you subscribe to on Youtube.
So we can kind of see like who the WHO,
the big bloggers who are,
um,
uh,
so,
but it's,
but it's really tough.
You know,
sometimes we'll get the,
you know,
adult answers from teenagers and there'll be like,
a capital letter,
you know,
they'll,
they'll speak,
they'll speak very formally,
and then other times we'll get,
um,
uh,
you know,
let's see.
I think I may be put,
um,
well I guess I capitalized most of the things,
but like the way the kids were applying to me,
you could tell it was like,
they're doing this,
like they're texting one of their friends.
It's like totally incorrect grammar,
misspellings everywhere.
Um,
and that's kind of one of the invitations for like,
all right,
this person's being really real versus if they were typing like real
professional life.
But,
but uh,
yeah,
it's hard.
It's really,
really hard.
Um,
people are biased.
but yeah,
in short,
a couple of things that we do is,
one,
we use our own platform into,
we have a group of teen ambassadors that will go and ask the questions for us.
So it's a teenager talking to a teen,
not an old person talking to a team.
One question,
what happens after the graduation to the after school accounts for after school?
It happens after graduation is they're kicked out.
Um,
eventually we'll build a college product,
but to keep,
uh,
you know,
to keep,
uh,
the,
the network,
just high schoolers,
we have to kick them out.
So we've picked out,
yeah,
million plus users.
One last question.
Um,
see any,
so you say that there was some Munoz do it too.
Now I'm on the team to juice.
Yeah.
Um,
did you see any like,
tell me,
seeing him kind of agile.
Let's do it.
Thanks.
Ideas,
help me off.
Yeah.
So,
so her question was,
um,
you know,
she has an eight year old daughter that's making slime and selling it.
And,
uh,
is this generation,
do I see any ideas,
uh,
from,
from teenagers that are,
are,
are trying to make change?
And,
you know,
I see it every day.
It's,
it's,
it's really cool.
There's,
there's one a 18 year old that I'm working with that's,
I'm trying to make Vegan chicken nuggets to make,
uh,
you know,
us all be vegetarians and trying to be like a teen brand and make being,
being a vegetarian.
Cool.
Um,
uh,
and yeah,
so that's just one example of a,
of a teenager being like,
this is a real problem.
Um,
and you know,
he's taking matters into his own hands and trying to create the Vegan version of
Mcdonald's.
Um,
uh,
and,
I've seen that.
Yeah.
Dozens of times.
So it's inspiring.
Thank you all for listening and hopefully you're a little more knowledgeable on
today's
teenager.